do you think Nile wheeze in the shower
yes or no
oh
I'm not horn and this is us the audience
for that Bible right here we go
[Music]
who would Nile call First in an
emergency my lawyer
and he probably gave him a show in most
cases who would I call
yeah probably my girlfriend she'd have
the best chance of helping me I'd
imagine who do you think they said they
probably said Capaldi or something like
that
President Biden three percent
I met the guy once for about 15 minutes
I mean he could probably help because he
was the president of the United States I
have an inn do you think he'd respond to
the call probably not well three percent
that's low let's see what we got above
Harry Styles seven percent that's crazy
that the leader of the Free World
again he got four percent less than
Harry Styles uh yeah I'd give Harry
Harry a show he's um
he would give concrete advice good in an
emergency situation uh a relaxed figure
yeah I'm sure it would yeah he needs
those yeah you need people like that
number two Lewis Capaldi ten percent
no he'd freak out he'd be he'd be more
freaked out than me
so I'm not giving him a shout
um yeah he would be he'd be all over the
place I'd have to I'd actually have to
help it would work in Reverse I'd call
him and then I'd have to talk him down
um yeah that's right number one let's
see what we got
his mom 43 yes I give my mother a shout
yeah although she'd probably freak out
too so
not great ones
next one if Noel changed his hairstyle
what would suit him next
what would I get I don't know I don't
have the head for a mullet
and also too many people are doing it I
just
God I don't know let's see what happens
my God
that is
wow
um none of them oh really oh yeah that's
a shame yeah I probably would have went
for none of them I think probably number
two is probably closer
the one second from left is probably the
closest I've been how'd you feel about
the little like ponytail one no no okay
no I'm okay thanks all right here we go
let's see what the people said
46 for number two I was right yeah I had
a feeling about that so that is actually
someone famous as her yeah
there's a bit of gray in there this is
Paul mascal you are correct no offense
Paul
I've just aged You by saying that next
one we asked the public do you think
Nile wheeze in the shower
yes or no
oh
should we just do uh
the court of public opinion um let's see
what happens
87 said yes
thoughts on that no comment your honor
okay
yes
oh they know me and they don't know me
as well you know at the same time
this is this is fun
this is good who should play Nile in a
movie about his life I always get Alan
Leach who isn't um a guy for an Irish
guy from Downton Abbey
um and uh yeah I seen him one day in a
coffee shop in L.A and we got chatting
because he was doing an interview with
Ellen or something like that and it got
brought up that he looks exactly like me
and it's crazy when I seen him I was
like oh we actually do he's a great
actor he's Irish so the accent wouldn't
have to change too much and he looks
pretty much like me
it's either him or Brad Pitt
five Killian Murphy one percent one
percent of people said kill him Murphy I
have a feeling that the next four are
also Irish
oh Owen Wilson wow I'm not sure where
that came from but wow have you ever
seen that that noise going around wow
wow wow five percent of people said on
Wilton
three said Zac Efron no to kill him
Murphy nor Tom Wilson Zac Efron I'll
take it makes me more handsome
two Paul maskel 18 of people said Paul
mascal
it's not Mezcal as people have been
saying it's definitely masculine
um yes also a nice extremely handsome
Irishman
um so yeah and he's brilliant he do you
think is the who do you think the top
the top person's gonna be
[Music]
um I actually thought number one would
have been killing Murphy just because of
how popular he is uh Who's the who could
it be let's find out
Tom Holland 23 percent
um yes I'll take that yeah yeah
do you know Tom I do know Tom yes I've
played a bit of gold for him don't know
about his Irish accent his English one's
pretty good
um he's uh yeah great lad and um really
good actor as we know so I'll take that
the lineup is pretty strong actually the
Old Milton one knows a bit a bit weird
all right but gladly I can't believe
that four percent more people thought to
own Wilson was better than killing
what reality TV show should Nile appear
on I'm a celebrity get me out of here
it's probably don't want to go for
um how would you fare with the bugs
claustrophobia very bad at that okay
not good with small spaces uh the rest
of it I think will be all right food as
well I'd get like Ian Wright angry when
I'm hungry
um let's see what
the Traders five percent love the
trailers bloody Grace oh my God what a
great shot brilliant shot
um that's a little percentage anyway
MILF Manor
what have you heard of it no okay so
it's basically like a bunch of MILFs in
a house and then they bring in it's like
meant to be a dating show they think
it's a dating show and they bring in
their sons so all the women Sons
holy
that is ballistic
weirdly enough no
I do want to watch it though yeah
naked attraction God no absolutely not
I'm not getting my feet out for anyone
never mind anything above that 12 that
was SAS who dares wins absolutely not
couldn't think of anything worse
honestly just foxy roaring in my face
for no reason
um all right foxy you're on camera shout
as loud as you can and he would Roar at
me I'd be useless
don't hurt me uh number one the Great
British Bake Off
honestly now I really know what people
think of me they really do think I'm
just like the most vanilla man ever
how do you think you're far on vehicle
do you think I'll be useless yeah
terrible I've never
I'm not doing that not great not great
ones actually I'm raging
um
I'm a celebrity would have been the one
I would have went with which Hogwarts
house would not be in Gryffindor
Ravenclaw Hufflepuff Slytherin right I'm
going to take out Slytherin
and Ravenclaw I'm going to leave a and C
in Gryffindor and Hufflepuff as you can
see here
um are you are you hired Harry Potter
fan not to the extent that I would stick
myself in a one of the houses but if I
but uh I don't give up
um Gryffindor
let's see what I would go for Gryffindor
they're probably saying Hufflepuff let's
see what happens
how do I know
um it's a good one like it's The
Underdogs I know it's a bit harmless
though isn't it yes it is so the traits
are like hard-working yeah nice to a
fault okay and
um kind
and just like good people okay uh I'll
take it but they are known as the
Selfies aren't they
yeah but Cedric Diggory was in hospital
okay he's all right he's a good guy yeah
okay I'll take it it could have been
worse
could it uh next one we asked the public
what is Nile's dream date well I always
like when I remember like growing up and
you couldn't go anywhere like I always
hated the idea of like Cinema remember
like Cinema used to be a day like when
you were young especially coming from
small town did you do the arm yeah yeah
a lot of that stuff I mean it's the
worst thing in the world to do go to the
cinema
just like pure silence you have to watch
the movie when you when do you get a
chance to actually get to know anyone
um so no not day uh not that I would say
good restaurant that you can both agree
on is good
um and then maybe go to the pub
afterwards because I feel like people
are more relaxed in pubs I think we like
the idea of
sitting down at the fancy restaurant
table and doing all that stuff but the
more relaxed you can be on a date the
better let's have a look at the options
is
Netflix and chill yeah I do a lot of
that I do like that crazy girls I
absolutely hate that's probably going to
be high on the list I despise it I'm
useless at it for a girlfriend terrible
at it D Karaoke uh it is that's that's
fun see that's that's in order that
would happen like he would go pint in
the pub your restaurant fight in the pub
you know if it's first date stuff you
get to know each other quite well and
it's a bit of a laugh then you end up in
some underground karaoke place in SoHo
um what would you be singing I obviously
I don't know why New York State of Mind
by Billy Joel oh wow yeah it sits in my
vocal range for everyone do you want to
give us the rendition
[Laughter]
sound like a bag of screaming cats
um I'd say people went to a crazy golf
or painting the pub I would say a pint
in the pub but
Crazy Golf 37 of people that said Tracy
God and I despise it yeah they really
look the people who think they know me
um but they're not crazy golf is a
disaster I'd never do that yeah because
you want to be good at something though
if you're going to do an activity you
want to be half decent at it
um yeah but it's maybe it's quite an
embarrassing thing to be good at like
it's it's cool to not be good at it yeah
it probably is yeah and bowling like
it's not there's my excuse yeah they're
good yeah take over it too cool yeah
why did One Direction break up I was on
the right lines I was on the right lines
yeah
are you single okay
predictable
when a One Direction Getting Back
Together there you go there you go
another point to me do you have an
answer to that I've got no no I did
hopefully one day hopefully